[Musique]
notre premier candidat masculin
monsieur fabien un sportif très mal moi
j'ai eu peur du jeu comme mitterrand
l'autre jour il est bien bagaric on
applaudit tracé c'est la présidente du
syndicat
[Applaudissements]
ça va magali ça va tu es contente d'être
venue alors est ce qu est ce que tu as
fait c'était dimanche aujourd'hui est ce
que tu as fait un bon déjeuner j'ai
mangé ou
madame ses cousines avec madame mamie
béji ben mami belgique
qu'est ce que tu avais fait à manger ma
vie belgique et près de terre des
scrutins
mais encore du poisson et des macaronis
[Musique]
et les croquer et des croisés basit en
jambes ne manque que vous avez pu
remonter jusque jusqu'au théâtre
je suis sûr qu'il n'habite pas paris ou
est-ce que tu habites j'aimerais
entendre vieira rude à la france et la
belgique
c'est en belgique
[Musique]
gâtés lors que les partis ce matin de
frameries ravages à monsieur le faire à
sakal du soir cas c'est tout ça ça s'est
très tôt et alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé après on n'arrivait jamais on
croyait qu'on arrive à l' as far as oui
c'est vrai qu'il ya un décalage horaire
avec la belgique ont connu des méridiens
et laure tu es venu tout seul où tu es
venu avec ta famille avec ma famille
alors dit moi ta famille qui s'est passé
mon papa et ma maman mamie alors où ils
sont parents savent pourquoi et comment
il s'appelle papa papa l'a dit freddy je
leur ai dit qu'est ce qui fait comme
métier
madame et puis est il normal de trois
gendarmes du zoo ici des femmes
les gens vont de colby
oui oui mais aussi les aubois pas ma
jambe me voient comme une fois réparé
et boivent dépeinte à la jambe dans le
mobile art à ses débuts et il boit de
l'eau du bain j'en étais sûr c'est un
copain à moi combien il voit par jour 2
3 2 3 1
sarko veut pour l'instant joueurs autant
que deux chevaux dit
toi tu vois pas demain maman boit du vin
un peu mieux de livres abbas et parrain
de nuit
[Applaudissements]
quelle famille et qu'est ce qu'il fait
en papa comme métier inspecteur des
impôts mais un inspecteur gentil
à réécouter montre le moi ton papa
montre le volet où il est bon jour aussi
inspecteur bonjour à jamais salie
puisque vous êtes à l'inspecteur gentil
on va demander à ce que vous soyez nommé
auprès des artistes voyez carlos alors
il a dit pas il a dit que son père était
un aspirateur 21.6 rathore des impôts et
bien écoutez monsieur on va tout de
suite demandé ce que ça y est nommé
auprès de nous parce qu'on a besoin d'un
inspecteur compris ans il ya pas de
raison pour tout le monde il faut qu'ils
ont nommé pour tout le monde vous serez
nommé jon ministre des finances à ça
qu'est ce qu'il fait donc papa tu sais
le comment de quoi être déçu
c'est un bon mais dieu a été vraiment le
travail aussi
oui elles sont quelques mois
vous voyez valable il y à des progrès
maintenant les enfants reconnaissent
véritablement que c'est un travail que
de s'occuper d'eux alors quand tu seras
grande toi est ce que tu as déjà choisi
un métier lequel un fait
[Applaudissements]
dans les bars et bistrots fait voix eh
bien oui mais comment résister et là je
[Rires]
et bien tu vois même line renaud ne nous
avait pas fait ça tout ce que tu veux si
tu seras grand
carole
attends là largement à quelques
explications
danseuse oui et sainte vierge pour être
auprès du jésus à pointe et qui c'est
jésus dit
et qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé à jésus
je me détourne la tête
obama qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand
tu seras grande famille ramasser les ça
c'est un joli métier alors ça c'est un
beau métier de ramasser les oeufs tu
aimes bien ramasser les oeufs ça c'est
un vrai vrai mais est-ce que c'est papa
maman ramasse les noms des fois à la
masseuse d'offres aussi très bien mais
d'en apprendre belle mais qu'est ce qui
les fait les eaux l'année passée c'est
une famille formidable c'est maman qui
fait les ça c'est formidable alors pas
monsieur vous ne manquerez pas
d'omelette thème bien manger
oui qu'est ce que tu aimes le mieux ben
oui car tout y est alors oui surtout pas
c'est normal
et puis à amasser 10 15 et 20 ans et je
fais toujours la nuit veut il fait
d'ailleurs la libye calculé tu fais la
nuit
basket c'est catastrophique
ya que toi qui ça arrive dans la famille
à qui est-ce qui pète encore et à
patrick
ça vous fait beaucoup de bruit quand
dans le quartier oui c'est marrant
rencontré une famille comme pour ça
qu'elle danse bien les enlevant et toi
qu'est ce que tu manges et la poupe du
poids tant tout peu de poissons que mon
papy perçu et outils digis kebabs et
autres parce que tonton papilles pêche
le chiche kebab là et parce que la poupe
de poisson l'atout peau de poisson c'est
drôlement bon la soupe de poisson est ce
que tu as choisi un métier pour quand tu
seras grand
oui lequel on peut voir la voyez tout
pour l'éducation nationale n'y a pas de
problème et les gentils ta maîtresse à
l'école hu
comment elle s'appelle des fois j'en
tout ça parce qu'il ya des fois où elle
est pas gentil
ouais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait quand elle
est pas gentille elle mais d'étranges
way est détrempée qu'est ce que c'est
une trempe lots et l'on donne souvent
c'est marrant cette fête reste y quand
ce n'est pas gentil il donne des trempes
aux autres et toi qu'est ce que tu veux
faire quand tu seras grand a doctor
qu'est ce qui t'attire dans le métier de
docteur
non
c'est dit 1 les amener à vent et viens
tu je te trouve très sympathique très
fin très naturel je veux devenir docteur
il ya du pognon et on va défendre avoir
un
qu'est ce que tu vas nous chanter si
bolbec c'est beau la vie
c'est la première fois que tu vois
patrick juvet comment tu le trouves
quand tu le trouves il était elle te
trouves habillée du tout est beau
[Musique]
c'était des grandes marées rupture le
mal que les gens qui l'aiment pas picot
serait clos débat il retient pépère
elle a voulu dire que je suis pas vieux
clou je crois que tu peux pleurer avec
moi mon pote wimax romain rigaux c'est
vrai il sera père oui
par ap ben oui il est sympa ton père
oui il pense que tu es une fille sophie
mette ça va être maintenu son père qui
pensent copie c'est une famille
dynamique apparemment révèle à la fois
hélas me disent que toi c'est bien tu la
vois à la télévision mireille mathieu
sauvage wcs pas souvent et les jolies
marierait bien avec elle ah oui sermier
[Musique]
pourquoi suis-je mm alors libera bijoux
je lève trop attention à rester sérieux
attendait les fiançailles
viens là vient sur le plateau ah bah non
c'est pas pour toi voilà et mike good
bye une bague de fiançailles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors dis donc tu sais que c'est la
première fois depuis que je fais l'école
des femmes où je vois un petit garçon
offrir une caisse que c'est une bague de
fiançailles pour te marier attend à et
tuer tu veux te marier avec dorothée oui
dorothée êtes vous prêt à prendre pour
épouse pour époux monsieur sébastien
turay qui si vous permettez que je fasse
connaissance de la famille
[Applaudissements]
c'est ta fiancée
oui c'est ton fiancé alors pouvez vous
embrasser alors pourquoi pas ce que je
bois encore varier en europe lit plus de
2000 ans j'ai déplacé tous les os et
c'était tout
genre je le savais ils disent
super ça lui a pris le comble c'est que
c'est moi qui me suis trompé mais tu as
raison mais mais non mais il a il a
parfaitement raison qu'est ce que tu
avais appris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu avais appris mort d'un
robot et ben chante no more d'un robot
tout seul non mais c'est vrai que là tu
vas t'asseoir pardon quitte à tromper
moi je lui ai dit papa d'une fausse
phrase alors est ce que tu peux chanter
mort d'un robot maintenant moi je te
garantis que personne ne veut faire
tromper
tout y est oui et si ça va pas hésite
pas donné un coup de poing
puissiez-vous pas se laisser faire mon
avis un rapport tacle puis s'est donné
un coup de poing var comment tu fais ont
fait voir aux devoirs points alors s'il
approche d'accord vas-y chante mort d'un
robot comment ça commence voire d'un
robot basics
tout fabriqué bien trop blâmer pour les
jeux
20 bon d'accord
il embête aura conquis deux tours d'amis
nature aux tiers le groupe homogène qui
doit pour tâter le pauvre homme dénommé
rami petit été
un teint
il garde
en ce qui
mamie tu es
bravo s'épargner qu'est-ce qui manque
williams a les mêmes ben oui alors chose
à fin mai valait net a picture maladie
les doux rêves de été ou qu'as-tu fait
un mètre de la foreuse la petit à petit
1 on va partir chaque jour il faut que
je revoie ma si tu veux pas rester ou
non ça t'embête consulte bourg oui alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse
ta fille je vais passer
sont calcaires
[Musique]
tu pleures parce que tu es content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]